hello and welcome to lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. is specifically pacific right here
on gamespot com I'm your host Daniel
dire hey doing folks it's gonna video
games are happening Justin hey walls
here alexa ray korea's here but we're
going to talk first of all not
necessarily the video games kind of
video games kind of about Star Wars kind
of at Disney what the hell's going on
d23 was on over the weekend my twitter
feed was just like a bunch of weird [ __ ]
all happening at the same time yeah i
was at d23 it's like the biannual disney
expo and because we have a lot of
marvelous Star Wars things happening
this year there was a big star wars
exhibit big Marvel exhibits a lot of
news came out of that we saw trailers
for Doctor Strange and which hasn't
started filming yet but we have footage
hi and they captain america civil war
yeah right any strange doctor different
it's still it's still hard for me to
wrap my head around that Disney isn't
it's not just a house of the mouse it's
the house of Star Wars and House of
Marvel and lighten it so when are they
just gonna by Nintendo that's next ok so
let's start we'll dive into all the
different bits and bobs that you saw
when we were there in a second but like
what to Justin's point what's the vibe
like there because we go to something
like III and it's like oh well here for
video games or you go to like you know
comic-con it's kind of like oh we're all
here for like comics I kind of movies as
well whereas this is like there's so
many pies it's touching it's like
everything from toys to live video games
to like Star Wars stuff too like crazy
vintage Disney's oh yeah what's it like
there so number one the bar to get in is
very high the tickets are like two
hundred dollars Wow and there it's a
three day event um it was it smelled
wonderful and it was a it was not
crowded like I so they had on display
the new storm troopers from the force
awakens they had captain phasma czar mer
set up like for you and then they had
like a display with ray infants costumes
and one of the bb-8 props cool that's a
little Bowl thing right oh no he's this
big oh right real he's like this big was
he like did you get to see him move like
his he's a practical effect that he yeah
actually moves around on see did you get
to like see him in action I didn't get
to see move but I touched him in someone
yelled at me and man and when he turned
around I touched him again so um but uh
the leak is rolling away the exhib
were roped off but you could get right
up to the edge of that exhibit like it
wasn't crowded people weren't like
smashed around it it was just people
taking photos moving on how many people
Rob base what they feel like oh my god
it's hard to tell you on a scale of like
12 san diego comic-con it was maybe like
a four we're not crowded at all there
was space like I was never caught in a
crowd there's a letter to move did you
think you up for stuff like get in line
yes there were there were there were
lines to buy things like they did okay
to Disney specific stores with exclusive
merchandise and art stuff and the lines
for those are maybe like an hour loll
the collectors are going to be Disney
has been science I mean not just with
the number of races that they do that
sell out almost immediately now every
year but all the different pens now all
the merchandise related to starve
already pens pens t-shirt people people
line up they will go to these events
just to get a pen just to get this
special t-shirt that says I was Disney
at star wars on 2014 august fourteenth
and then load you know do a different
shirt for the next day yep and they're
so good at like like this is in a
bizarre way affect logistics like one of
the best things about going to Disney
World is like going to the car park and
seeing a welding just how well they have
that down to a science and then I'm so
happy to work there like even the people
who is just like I'm gonna give you a
hot dog he's smiling yeah I'm happy to
be weird so nice to see the attendance
that were shops it up and there were
people you know did forcers or whatever
and everyone's just so nice I get bumped
and people be like I'm so sorry but some
of the best cosplay I've ever seen like
it was just the whole vibe was just
magical and awesome there were a lot of
kids hmm the kids were always friendly
kind of thing yeah it's a very very
friendly family friendly convention
their big exhibit this year was they
were previewing that new avatar films
they had like variants okay look I
thought you forgot like yo own avatar
sure yeah avatar and then they had a big
setup detailing the building plans for a
Disneyland Shanghai which looks like
it's gonna be gonna be so they have a
whole Tron ride with the light cycles
and everything that they're building
annoyed them yeah like I think that's
what it is and then there's a like a toy
story themed hotel will it be as good as
the knockoff world of warcraft just on
the power theme park that's in China
I've ever seen that right it's awful
yeah there's a fake world of warcraft
like that it's a total ripoff it is a
world of warcraft theme park
but not officially everything what name
where is it it's in somewhere in China
yeah yeah oh girl word we should go
that'd be a pretty good I was nice to be
so cynical about Disney and the things
they did especially when I was younger
but now like as I get older I'm more I
like I found it even more endearing and
the like I love going to Disney now it's
like it is literally a magical
experience did you see Angelina Jolie
while you were there no I didn't but I
was about 10 feet away from Daisy Ridley
and John boyega okay Rey and Finn in the
new Star Wars movie I saw them on the
stage for disney infinity which has a
new force awakens force we can set yeah
yes about that they're doing they only
showed a brief clip they showed a rayon
Finn I love I was talking to john van
yaki who's mr. infinity and he said that
they showed Daisy Ridley her her figure
and she just like was so ecstatic and
she the one thing that she said was all
you got my shoulders right like thank
you they do those figures so well and
they look exactly like them but they
have the force awakens playset I did get
a chance to play the rise against the
Empire and twilight of the Republic I
think it's think they're called the to
the prequel trilogy and the original
Star Wars trilogy sets and I have high
hopes for the force awakens set from
what I played like there are a lot of
fun it's very much wish fulfillment I
drove the Millennium Falcon into the
Death Star and blood and there was like
this sequence where you have to maneuver
to get out and his explosions and
everything it's the only game they're
the figures right now um this is the
only game where you can beat up Darth
Maul with Olaf the snowman hahaha which
kind of something that I wanted Johnny's
lines no it doesn't gonna monitor I'm
like really really really really looking
forward to playing it and I like it and
I played you know some of battlefront at
events and whatnot but I will love about
disney infinity is it's just like that
sense of wonder and that sense of like
you can do anything I played his Boba
Fett and took down in 8018 you can just
do whatever you want it's great i love
it that's excellent are their last bits
and bobs that you like to mention from
will get to kingdom hearts another
second but apart from that any other
little bits and bobs you saw there like
kind of stuck out to you things things
you like to bed d23 that you probably
like to see in likes a video game shows
that we get to go to all the time it was
so well organized and people were so
just positive and everyone was just
like I really like I don't know I'd love
to see these events where everyone is I
feel like everyone at d23 like there was
this big dynnys disney interactive panel
right on Sunday morning and everyone got
like this exclusive like Kingdom Hearts
Mickey costume for Disney infinity and
of course a lot of people go to that
panel just to get like the exclusive
thing and like the free stuff or
whatever but everyone who was there like
the energy in the room and the energy
when we were leaving and sort of that
whole mess of cons when you're getting
in and out of big rooms everyone was
just really respectful and really happy
and everyone was there because they
wanted to be there and no one was really
like crappy yeah and I would love to see
that everywhere do you know what this
actually reminds me of is when we went
to blizzcon last year as I was blown
away by how it felt totally different to
a gamescom or an e three threes kind of
it zombies and even a pax were like
people were kind of rushing around to
see everything at pax and I gamescom
it's very much like a getting early
trying to see as much as you can get to
the lines quick whereas when we went to
blizzcon it felt like it was just like a
party everyone got to go to the talks
they wanted to go to and then the lines
were in that long either well it's also
helped by not having a ton of everything
I blizzcon is going to be a very focused
event on plz my games in Disney even as
much as there are so many different
things there's enough for everybody to
see all these and there were some
announcements we got to see the new
console and things like that but
otherwise like you get to everyone gets
to be a part of those things where is in
an e3 or a pax like this is your first
chance to see a lot of stuff and so yeah
you're gonna be in a rush because
otherwise you're gonna be in line for
four hours yeah for sure
you